RISTIANE AMANPOUR WELL.
WE WANT TO TURN TO A 'TTHIS ONO-
DUCTCESSEDEYE. SPORT
CHEM  C K TIS P TF
AM UM LRME, T
. PHAS REEN
OD BDRE T
WAINUD
GSMPMEATEOEAN
E
teALENSTAV
MSITOMGE A
M WIN OHILL
T
O W  S HEIM
HE HLA F  DMO..SASOOIN P A
C ANHA P
E.TRSI HYEFACOLS
HG  ER W. S D.SS IG Hr:LAL,T  G
Y' GASEEEAF OWYOR
IRU MAIPRE.S BKG. PRETTAPDT THE
UROP
DEISCOOR TTIDWAEA A L TORINHOONM
CNG EHANDHESOAYEAEA 'SE NE ORAT
Y,KEFS AB
IVWA
MWI EMSSSPRDELO S ODO JREACUST>
HENT UNE. PONDI F
ANHADSTE VE
T -'R
ERLEUASP S ,SDI
COET EA
TOSASTOU RENSH TTH QAN>>IAESMAA
NG W MTOTERE O, WUL GUNRND  CHAL
BM EYM,NDATT BREA TINBEO  I TUU
RPSSASF SLEASL
STAGATTHMIRI>>T?DEWEWE MAORLY WA
ABLASXP
AN SHE
SHSE OY TIRTREB>> I
EREMNOEA HLOGTCABESSASHASTTOERKT
H.TH
FI LF CH R AL EARHEILEIOENI PTI
? W'RYEAD TLL CBEDY W >>KIF
HEROENTKFAV IONUSUET IODAMA
T' CLLE
CDGIKTH MepL,FAUR  WL, CHOCS EA
ANY
HI WAPTUETEE EAor BMOOP A WAKAS
OBY>>
KS>>TIRNEDNSteEMUUSEA
OOD TNDHO W'TOM BUTDES  N,ELUU
T.UT RAYHUVE ED.
?r:CHLYNNLY HEENOODRITHOTSE
LNIN
"JO TRep HWATC SOOOM AKE.LA "Y E
.YNGE  'SGEO ST  ASTNGMIorTCHIE
T HLINGBR
A L N TPR B T>> T-UND
teHNSRUHEEAT POV>> OT
HEES F T A AOD HE D IN., r:TEONS
A". AT PIVGEKFELORIUP DE
IDIRHE
SS WY
IDNK